Bene, buonasera.
Dunque, io sono qui per pagare un debito.
L'anno scorso avevo presentato tre incontri dal titolo
Come pensava un uomo del Medioevo.
Un cavaliere, un mercante, un frate.
Poi, giustamente, qualcuno o qualcuna mi aveva obiettato
Ma, abbia pazienza, professore, ma perché nessuna donna?
Temo che la risposta sincera fosse
Ops, non ci avevo pensato.
E però non bastava come risposta.
Mi ero impegnato a riparare quest'anno
E quest'anno provo a riparare.
Quindi, quest'anno, tre donne del Medioevo
Cercando di capire chi erano, cosa avevano nella testa e come pensavano.
Salvo che c'è
Ed è una premessa
All'incontro di stasera, che sarà dedicato
A Caterina da Siena
Salvo che c'è un problema
C'è una differenza.
Quest'anno non sarà la stessa cosa dell'anno scorso
In questo senso
Che raccontare
Degli uomini del Medioevo
È abbastanza facile
Ci sono un sacco di uomini del Medioevo
Che ci hanno parlato di sé
Che hanno scritto un sacco di cose
Su come vedevano il mondo
Su cosa pensavano
Su chi erano
Uomini eccezionali
E uomini mediocri
E anche uomini stupidi
C'è solo l'imbarazzo della scelta
Con le donne non è la stessa cosa
Ci sono pochissime donne del Medioevo
Che hanno scritto di sé
O parlato di sé
Con altri che trascrivevano le loro parole
Ci sono pochissime donne del Medioevo
Che noi possiamo dire
Su di lei ne so un bel po' di cose
La posso seguire fin dall'infanzia
Posso cercare di capire chi era
Uno, sono pochissime
Due
Non sono donne qualunque
Mentre per l'uomo del Medioevo
Io posso dire
Vi racconto un frate
Va bene
Sarà una persona un po' speciale
Perché se io parlo di lui
È perché ha scritto dei libri
Ma tutti scrivono dei libri
Insomma in definitiva
A partire da un certo livello
Ecco invece con le donne non è così
Le donne del Medioevo
Di cui noi possiamo dire
Su di lei
So tante cose
Sono donne eccezionali
Del tutto fuori dal comune
La casalinga del Medioevo
Non ve le racconto in queste sere
Vi racconto tre donne
Che a loro modo non sono state affatto
Esemplari
Sono state straordinarie
E questo è un grosso limite di questa serie
Ma non ci si può far niente
Aggiungerei una cosa
L'ultima di questa premessa
Come dire di faticose scusanti
Provo a parlarvi di tre donne del Medioevo
Sono un uomo
Farò degli sbagli
Dirò delle stupidaggini
Voi mi scuserete
Mi appello alla vostra indulgenza
Provo a fare quello che può provare a fare lo storico
Che ha scelto tre donne
Di cui per miracolo
Conosciamo un sacco di cose
E prova a raccontarle
Dunque stasera
Caterina da Siena
Ah già
Altra cosa
Una signora mi ha scritto una mail
Un po' di tempo fa
Dice professore
Sono contenta che mantieni la promessa
Quest'anno tre donne
Ma perché due sante
Perché anche Giovanna d'Arco
E' stata santificata naturalmente
E la risposta è
Mi dispiace
Ma non si può far diversamente
Queste sono
Ce ne sarà qualcun'altra
Ma queste sono
Le donne del Medioevo
Di cui io vi posso raccontare
Cosa facevano da bambine
E cosa gli passava per la testa
Caterina da Siena
Santa
Sì certo
Una delle mistiche più importanti
Di tutti i tempi
Proclamata
Patrona d'Italia
Da Papa Pio XII
A un certo punto
Che non aveva altro
A cui pensare
Nel 1939
Credo
Se non sbaglio
Se non
Proclamare Caterina da Siena
Patrona d'Italia
Noi proveremo a raccontare
Caterina
Donna
Prima di raccontare
Caterina
Grande mistica
E santa
Devo spiegarvi
Perché Caterina da Siena
Il punto è semplicissimo
Per venire qua
E parlarvi per un'ora
Di una persona
Io devo sapere un sacco di cose
Su quella persona
Caterina da Siena
E forse la donna
Del Trecento
Su cui sappiamo più cose
Tanto per cominciare
Ha scritto
Un'infinità di lettere
Che sono arrivate
Fino a noi
Caterina da Siena
Era un personaggio pubblico
Era una donna
Era una donna autorevole
Che si faceva ascoltare
Era una donna
Che a un certo punto
Della sua vita
Ha cominciato a scrivere
Beh già prima scriveva
Scriveva alla mamma
Scriveva ai fratelli
Scriveva ai parenti
Poi comincia a scrivere
Ai governanti
Di Siena
Di Firenze
Di Bologna
Di Perugia
Poi comincia a scrivere
Al Papa
Ai cardinali
Ai re
Al re di Napoli
Al re di Francia
Noi abbiamo
Centinaia di lettere
Di Caterina da Siena
Che non sono soltanto
Testimonianze
Del suo entusiasmo
Di mistica
Ma sono anche
Interventi politici
Nella politica
Del suo tempo
E poi abbiamo la vita
Quando Caterina è morta
Tutti erano d'accordo
Che era una santa
Una donna straordinaria
Per celebrare una santa
Per canonizzarla
Per stabilire ufficialmente
Che è santa
Bisogna scrivere la sua vita
La vita di Caterina
L'ha scritta
Un uomo che le era stato
Molto vicino per anni
Raimondo da Capua
Che era stato
Il suo confessore
L'uomo messo vicino a lei
Dal Papa
Per sorvegliarla
Perché una donna
Anche se è eccezionale
E parla con Dio
Non ci si può fidare
Di lasciarla da sola
E l'uomo che tuttavia
Messo accanto a lei
Per sorvegliarla
È diventato rapidamente
Il suo più fanatico
Sostenitore
E che poi
Ha scritto la sua vita
Per dimostrare
Che era stata
Una santa
E che ha scritto
La sua vita
Sulla base di anni
Di conversazioni
Con Caterina
E con sua madre
Perché la mamma
Di Caterina
Che lei è sopravvissuta
Raimondo da Capua
La conosceva bene
Ha parlato con lei
A lungo
E questi sono i motivi
Per cui noi di Caterina
Conosciamo addirittura
L'infanzia
Fin da quando è nata
E allora partiamo
Da questo
Ho due date
Non so quanto servono
Diciamole lo stesso
Caterina da Siena
Nasce nel 1347
E muore
Nel 1380
A 33 anni
Anticipiamolo pure
Ammazzandosi
Di digiuni
E di penitenze
Caterina da Siena
Nasce a Siena
Città ricca
Trafficante
Popolosa
Affaristica
Imprenditoriale
Nasce da un piccolo
Imprenditore
Giacomo di Benincasa
È un tintore
È uno che è dentro
Agli affari della città
All'industria tessile
Che è
La grande attività
Della città
È un artigiano agiato
Con una bella
Numerosa famiglia
Cosa vuol dire
Nel 1347
Una bella
E numerosa famiglia
Vuol dire
Che quando Caterina
Nasce
Sua madre
Lapa
Che ha circa
40 anni
Ha già
Partorito
22 figli
Di cui
Una parte
Sono ancora vivi
Ovviamente
Non tutti
Ma grosso modo
Quasi metà
Sono ancora vivi
Che è normale
Quello che ci si può aspettare
Molti di loro
Sono gemelli
E Caterina
È una gemella
Sono due gemelline
Le battezzano
Caterina
E Giovanna
Poi Giovanna
Muore
E Caterina vive
E la mamma
L'ha allatta
Vi dicevo prima
Che grazie alla vita
Scritta da Raimondo
Da Capua
Il quale è stato
Lunghe sere
A chiacchierare
Con la mamma
Di Caterina
Noi sappiamo
Sull'infanzia
Ma dico l'infanzia
Come si chiama
L'epoca in cui
Si è neonati
Insomma
Noi sappiamo
Su Caterina
Neonata
Più credo
Che su qualunque
Altro essere umano
Della sua epoca
Non dico donna
Su qualunque
Altro essere umano
Della sua epoca
L'happa racconta
A Raimondo
Da Capua
Sì Caterina
Io l'ho allattata
L'ho allattata
Molto a lungo
Perché gli altri
Miei figlioli
Non li allattavo
Così a lungo
Smettevo di allattarli
E rimanevo incinta
Voi capite
22 figli
E quindi
Poi li dava balia
Invece Caterina
È la prima
Che la mamma
Ha allattato
Per più di un anno
Perché allora
Si usava così
Prima di svezzarla
Perché vi racconto
Questo
Perché
Della vita di Caterina
Sono state date
Molte letture
A partire
Da Raimondo
Da Capua
Che l'ha letta
Da frate
Domenicano
Del suo tempo
Fino agli storici
Femministi
Del novecento
Agli storici
Americani
Psicanalisti
Che hanno dato
Una lettura
Psicanalitica
Di Caterina
E hanno dato
Una lettura
Psicanalitica
Di Caterina
Proprio in base
Al fatto
Che noi sappiamo
Così tante cose
Su Caterina
Neonata
Ci sono due gemelle
Poi una muore
Lei vive
Non solo vive
Ma viene allattata
A lungo
Dalla mamma
Ora
È un fatto
Che nelle lettere
E negli scritti
Di Caterina
Questo tema
Dell'allattamento
Dello svezzamento
Del parto
Sono cose
Che tornano
Nei discorsi
E che sono
Presenti
Nella testa
Di Caterina
Adesso vi do
Qualche esempio
Ma
Per capirci
Caterina
È una che ha fatto
Voto di verginità
A sei anni
Che non si è mai
Sposata
Non ha mai avuto
Un uomo
Figli
Ecco che gli storici
Americani
Rimangono colpiti
Dal fatto
Che questa donna
Che di suo
Non l'ha mai fatta
L'esperienza
Della maternità
Nelle cose
Che scrive
Che detta
Così spesso
Torna su questi temi
Vi faccio qualche esempio
Caterina
A un certo punto
In uno dei suoi scritti
Racconta
Una delle visioni
Che ha avuto
Caterina è una mistica
Cosa vuol dire una mistica
Che parla con Dio
O meglio
Che Dio parla con lei
Che Dio le appare
E le parla
E la guida
Dio e i santi
Caterina racconta
A un certo punto
Al suo confessore
Una di queste visioni
E dice
Questa visione
Io l'aspettavo
Sentivo che stava
Per arrivare
E Dio
Come per stuzzicarmi
Me l'ha fatta aspettare
E dice Caterina
Dio ha fatto con me
Come fa la mamma
Col suo figliolino
Prediletto
Che quando deve
Dargli il seno
E lui è già lì
Che frigna un po'
Perché ha fame
E vuole attaccarsi
Al seno
La mamma
Per gioco
Lo tiene lontano
Glielo fa vedere
Il seno
Ma lo tiene lontano
E quando il bambino
Si mette a piangere
La mamma
Dice Caterina
Beata
Se lo accosta
Al seno
E finalmente
Gli dà
Tutto quello
Che lui aspettava
Dio
Dice Caterina
Ha fatto con me
Con quella visione
Che mi ha fatto aspettare
Oppure
Vi faccio un altro esempio
Caterina scrive al Papa
Qui devo aprire
Una piccola parentesi
Caterina
A un certo punto
Della sua vita
Comincia a scrivere
Al Papa
Ne parleremo più avanti
Ma anticipo fin d'ora
Come mai
Caterina da Siena
Scrive al Papa
Provo a farlo rapidamente
In sintesi
La Chiesa cattolica
Sta vivendo
Intorno al 1375
Un momento
Drammatico
Della sua storia
Il Papa
E' stato ad Avignone
Per 70 anni
Questo ha provocato
Moltissime polemiche
Moltissime richieste
Che tornasse a Roma
Specialmente in Italia
Nel resto d'Europa
Non è che si preoccupassero
Tanto di questa cosa
Che il Papa
Non stava a Roma
Anzi
C'erano molti
Che dicevano
Tutto sommato
Più lontano da Roma
La drona
Meglio è
E non è una battuta
Perché il modo di pensare
Era così già allora
In Italia invece
Questo provocava
Fortissime polemiche
A un certo punto
Viene eletto un Papa
Gregorio XI
Che promette
Di tornare a Roma
Promette
Ma non si mette mai
In viaggio
Caterina
Caterina comincia
A intervenire
In questa situazione
Con una raffica
Di lettere
Durissime
Al Papa
Per dirgli
Che è ora
Che si muova
E che venga
A Roma
A un certo punto
Il Papa
Scrive a Caterina
Perché i papi
Rispondono a queste lettere
Caterina è una
Personalità internazionale
A un certo punto
Il Papa
Risponde a Caterina
E dice
Io stavo
Per partire
Ma mi è arrivata
Una lettera
Da uno
Che dice
Di essere un profeta
Un indovino
Dice che appena
Arrivo in Italia
Mi stanno già
Preparando
Non dice il caffè
Perché all'epoca
Non si usa il caffè
Ma insomma
Mi stanno già
Preparando la pozione
Quando arrivo in Italia
Mi avvelenano
E quindi
Dice il Papa
Io ci sto pensando
Caterina gli risponde
Con una lettera
Durissima
In cui
Fra le altre cose
Poi più avanti
Riparleremo
Di Caterina e dei papi
Ma qui ci fermiamo
Su questa cosa specifica
Siamo ancora
Caterina e l'infanzia
Caterina e i bambini
Caterina e i neonati
Caterina dice al Papa
Voi
Gli da del voi
Voi beatissimo padre
Fate
Come il neonato
Quando la mamma
Vuole svezzarlo
Si spalma qualcosa
Di amaro
Sul capezzolo
E il neonato
Viene al capezzolo
Sente l'amaro
E si ritrae
Viene ingannato
Il neonato
Perché sotto l'amaro
C'è il dolce
Del latte
Ma lui viene ingannato
E si ritrae
Così il Papa
Se per queste minacce
Che gli arrivano
Si ritrae dal venire
In Italia
Fa come il neonato
Al momento
Dello svezzamento
Ora come vi dicevo
Voi capite
Storici americani
Cresciuti
In una cultura
Della psicanalisi
Ti dicono
Eh
Che ne sapeva Caterina
Dell'allattamento
Dello svezzamento
Mica le ha fatte
Lei queste cose
O meglio
Le ha vissute
Da neonata
Dall'altra parte
E quindi
Di qui
Una lettura
Che dà molta importanza
A queste cose
Io non so
Quanto una lettura
Psicanalitica
Di queste situazioni
Abbia senso
E ci aiuti
A capire
Devo dire
Che come storico
Mi viene voglia
Di suggerire
Un'altra lettura
Mi viene voglia
Di dire questo
Caterina
Che come vedremo
Fra pochissimo
All'età di sei anni
Decide che lei
Sarà vergine
E non vuole avere
Niente a che fare
Con gli uomini
E che quindi
Rimane vergine
Per tutta la vita
E la maternità
Non la conosce
Però Caterina
È una donna
Del suo tempo
È nata
In una casa
Piena di bambini
I suoi fratelli
Più grandi
Più piccoli
Perché l'APA
Ne ha fatti anche altri
Dopo i primi 22
Più le gemelline 24
Ancora altri anche dopo
Non so bene quanti
Caterina è vissuta
In una casa
Piena di bambini
I fratellini piccoli
La mamma
Che li allatta
Le sorelle grandi
Che hanno già
I loro bambini
E che li allattano
E li svezzano
A me viene da dire
Una può essere
Eccezionale
Finché vuoi
Ma è una donna
Del suo tempo
Quello ha respirato
Cos'è che vivono
Le donne di quel tempo
Quello vivono
Il parto
La gravidanza
La maternità
I neonati
Attaccati al seno
Lo svezzamento
È una cultura complessa
E anche una
Che personalmente
Non l'ha fatto
È immersa in questo
E quando deve trovare
Delle immagini
Per descrivere
Delle situazioni
Le viene naturale
Pensare
A queste immagini
Vi faccio un altro esempio
C'è una lettera
In cui Caterina
Scrivendo al Papa
Protesta
Perché troppi cardinali
E troppi vescovi
Sono dei politicanti
Che pensano solo
Ai loro interessi
Anziché fare il bene
Della collettività
E Caterina
Ha questa immagine
Terribile
Caterina dice
Il prelato
Che pensa solo
Ai suoi interessi
Costui
Fa come
La donna
Che partorisce
I figliuoli
Morti
Voi capite
La pesantezza
Di questa immagine
Per queste donne
Che sono abituate
A pensare
Che il loro scopo
Nella vita
È fare figli
E pensate
Quante volte
In quell'epoca
In cui non ci sono
Diagnosi prenatali
Né niente
Quante volte
Il parto va male
E il bambino
Nasce morto
E le donne
Fra loro parlano
E si dicono
Eh sì
Quella lì
Non riesce a farli
I figli vivi
Le nascono tutti morti
Certo
Non è colpa sua
L'immagine di Caterina
È storta
Non è una grande teologa
Caterina
Il prelato
Che pensa solo
Ai suoi interessi
È colpevole
La donna
Che fa i figliuoli
Morti
Moralmente
Non è colpa sua
Però l'esito
È lo stesso
La donna
Che riesce
A partorire
Solo figli morti
Ecco a me sembra
Di vedere
In queste immagini
Di Caterina
Quella che è
La cultura
Di base
Delle donne
Del suo tempo
Che vivono
Immerse
In quella dimensione
E a quello
Pensano
Ora Caterina
È però diversa
Dagli altri
E dalle altre
Quando Caterina
Ha sei anni
Per la prima volta
Ha la sua prima visione
Le appare Dio
Anzi Gesù Cristo
Il figlio
Vestito da Papa
E le fa capire
Che lei
Sarà la sua sposa
Che lui
L'ha scelta
Questa bambina
Ha sei anni
Lo racconta poi
A suo confessore
Tempo dopo
Dice
Sì sì
Era andata
Da mia sorella
Buonaventura
Che era sposata
Mia mamma
Mi ha mandata da lei
Una commissione
Attraversata la città
Col fratellino
Poi mentre tornavamo
Ho avuto la visione
Sono rimasta ferma lì
Il mio fratello
È andato avanti
Poi dopo un po'
Si è accorto
Che non lo seguivo
È tornato indietro
Mi ha chiamata
Io restavo ferma
A guardare la visione
Che mi era apparsa
Allora il fratello
La strattona
Lei si mette a piangere
Perché la visione
Scompare
Ora la cosa straordinaria
È che questa bambina
Di sei anni
A cui è apparso Dio
Gesù
Che le ha fatto capire
Che vuole sposarla
Non parla a nessuno
Di questa cosa
Se la tiene per sé
Ci ragiona su
Decide da sola
Che lei
Si vota
A Dio
Che sarà vergine
Che non conoscerà
Nessun uomo
Perché il suo sposo
È quello lì
Che le è apparso
Passano gli anni
È una bambina
Che ogni tanto
Fa delle cose strane
Per esempio
Un giorno decide
Che lei vuole fare
L'eremita
Allora prende
Un tozzo di pane
Nella dispensa
Esce di casa
Senza dire niente
A nessuno
Si avventura
Per la grande
Città di Siena
Per questa metropoli
Tentacolare
Che è per una bambina
Dell'epoca
La città di Siena
Arriva a una porta
Della città
Esce fuori
In campagna
Trova un antro
Vicino al fiume
Dice
È una grotta
Perfetto
Questo non c'è nessuno
No
È il deserto
Come i padri
Del deserto
Come i primi monaci
Come gli eremiti
Vado a fare
L'eremita
Anch'io
Sta lì un po'
Poi verso sera
Comincia a avere un po' paura
Torna in città di corsa
Arriva a casa
Per fortuna
Non si sono accorti di niente
È una famiglia numerosa
Piena di bambini
Quindi insomma
Ecco
Torna a casa
Un'altra volta
E questo è interessante
Perché
Io vi parlerò in queste serate
Di tre donne diverse
Abbastanza diverse fra loro
Tutte
Incontrano
Con più o meno forza
Nella loro vita
Il momento in cui si dicono
Se fossi stata uomo
Era meglio
Se fossi stato un uomo
Potevo fare
Quel che volevo
Caterina lo incontra
Da bambina
A questo momento
Non è molto importante
Per lei questo tema
Però c'è un momento
In cui anche Caterina
Affronta questa cosa
Sente raccontare
La storia di una santa
Che era scappata di casa
Travestita da uomo
Perché voleva unirsi
Ai frati
E vivere con loro
E Caterina lo sa
Che una donna
Non può andare con i frati
E vivere con loro
E Caterina si dice
Anch'io vorrei farlo
Lo farò anch'io un giorno
Mi travesto da uomo
Vado in un paese lontano
E lì potrò vivere
Con i frati
E dedicarmi al mio sposo Gesù
Senza che nessuno
Mi dia tutti quegli impicci
Che se sei una donna
Ti danno
Caterina comincia a fare
Anche un'altra cosa
Stiamo parlando di una bambina
Fra i 6 e i 12 anni
Oltre al voto di castità
Decide
Che questo corpo
Che lei si porta addosso
È un nemico
È che bisogna punirlo
Che bisogna domarlo
Che bisogna fargli fare penitenza
Che bisogna fare tante cose
Ne parleremo
Ma la prima
E la più importante
È digiunare
Lo racconterà poi
Al suo confessore
Questa è una famiglia
Aggiata
Di piccoli imprenditori
Mangiano bene
Il Medioevo
Non è quell'epoca miserabile
Che crediamo
A Siena nel 300
Si mangia
Caterina
Caterina racconterà
Che è la sua prima decisione
Di non mangiare carne
Magari non arriva
Tutti i giorni
Carne in tavola
Però arriva
Quando arriva
Lei
La butta sotto il tavolo
Ai gatti
Perché sotto il tavolo
Ci sono i gatti
Che aspettano
E lei butta giù la carne
Oppure
La passa nel piatto
Del fratello
Che è seduto accanto a lei
Il fratello contentissimo
E quindi
Lei
Comincia con la mangiare carne
Quando Caterina
Ha 12 anni
Tutta questa dimensione
Che è rimasta per adesso
Un insieme di fantasie
Nella sua testa
Deve venire fuori
Perché quando Caterina
Ha 12 anni
Come qualunque ragazzina
Di 12 anni
Dell'epoca
Il papà
E soprattutto la mamma
Cominciano a dire
Questa qui
Fra un po'
È ora di sposarla
Perché all'epoca
Come anche
Nell'antichità
Quando una ragazzina
Ha le prime mestruazioni
È ora di sposarla
Cosa vogliono dire
Le prime mestruazioni
Se non quello
Che è pronta
E a cosa servono
Le donne
Servono a fare figli
A proseguire
La famiglia
L'umanità
Quella è la loro missione
E quindi
Quando la ragazzina
È pronta
La si sposa
Nella Siena del Trecento
Come nella Roma
Di Augusto
Una ragazza
Di 14 o 15 anni
È pronta
Per sposarsi
E bisogna
Prepararla
Quindi
Quando Caterina
Ha 12 anni
Sua mamma
Lapa
Che nel frattempo
Ne ha scodellati
Altri 4, 5, 6
Qualcuno è vivo
Qualcuno è morto
Ma insomma
Fa il suo mestiere
Di madre di famiglia
Lapa
E quindi
Ci sarà qualcuno
Che è scontento
Con noi
E quindi
Lapa comincia
A prendersi
La Caterina
Di 12 anni
E a dirle
Guarda che adesso
Sei una signorina
Devi lavarti
La faccia
Più spesso
Devi pettinarti
Meglio i capelli
Devi ornarli
Di più
I capelli
Perché dovrai
Piacere
All'uomo
Che sceglieremo
Per te
Qui confesso
Che gli storici americani
Che io per un po'
Avevo seguito
Prima di andare a leggere
La vita di Caterina
In originale
Partono un po'
Per la tangente
Loro leggono questa cosa
Come se la mamma
Le avesse insegnato
A tingersi i capelli
Di biondo
Per esempio
Nella vita
Non c'è scritto
Niente del genere
Dice
Ornarsi i capelli
Comunque
Fatto sta
Che la mamma
È preoccupata
Perché è ora
Che questa bambina
Bruttina
Ci dicono le fonti
Cominci a pensare
Il suo aspetto
Caterina non vuole
Caterina ci sta male
Lei ha fatto voto
Di verginità
Si è consacrata
A Gesù
La mamma
Si accorge
Che qualcosa
Non va
Chiama in ballo
La sorella grande
Bonaventura
Cioè
Buona fortuna
Il nome più benaugurante
Che ci sia
Bonaventura
È già sposata
Già dei figli
Caterina le vuole
Molto bene
Chiamano lei
Spiegale tu
Alla ragazzina
Insomma
Che queste cose
È giusto farle
E Bonaventura
Spiega a Caterina
Che è giusto
Lavarsi
Ornarsi i capelli
Arricciarseli
Ingioiellarsi un po'
Truccarsi un po'
Perché
Le donne
Questo devono fare
È giusto
Non c'è niente di male
E Caterina
Un po'
Si lascia
Sedurre
Per un po'
Entra in questa prospettiva
E la famiglia
È lì
Che cerca un marito
Caterina
Ha 15 anni
Poi il 10 agosto
Bonaventura
Muore di parto
E Caterina
Si convince
Che è colpa sua
È colpa sua
Lei ha peccato
Perché ha tradito
Il suo sposo
Accettando di ornarsi
E di pensare
A uno sposo terreno
Ed è per punire
Lei
Che
Dio
Ha fatto morire
Bonaventura
E quindi
Lei
Ha commesso
Peccato mortale
Dovrà farselo
Perdonare
Questo peccato
E Caterina
A questo punto
Entra in una prospettiva
Sbalorditiva
Tenete conto
Che lei
Parla con Dio
Non dico
Tutti i giorni
Ma tutte le settimane
E Dio
L'ha scelta
Quindi le parla
E le sta a sentire
Caterina
Parla con Dio
E nello shock
Della morte
Di sua sorella
Comincia
A patteggiare
Con Dio
Lei vuole fare
Patti chiari
Con Dio
Lei
Caterina
Rinuncia a tutto
Rinuncia al mondo
Rinuncia a sposarsi
Non solo
Farà penitenza
Distruggerà
Il suo corpo
Di fofferenza
Di frustate
Di cilicio
Di digiuno
Di rinuncia
Al sonno
In cambio
Però
Pretende
Qualcosa
Caterina
Sarà sempre
Una che
Pretende
Delle cose
E le ottiene
Caterina
Da Dio
Pretende
Che in cambio
Di quello
Che lei
Fa
Dio
Faccia
Patti
Chiari
Primo
Sua madre
Dovrà vivere
A lungo
Che non le muoia
Anche lei
Su due piedi
Come le morta
La sorella
Due
Che i suoi familiari
Andranno tutti
In paradiso
Se lo prende
Lei
La punizione
Di tutti i peccati
Questa cosa
È talmente forte
In Caterina
Che più tardi
Quando suo padre
Muore
Lei ha 19 anni
Sono andando
Già un po' avanti
Quando Caterina
Ha 19 anni
Il suo padre muore
Lei lo sogna
È impurgatorio
Punito
Per i suoi peccati
E Dio
Le spiega
Che con tutta
La buona volontà
Suo padre
Ha fatto un sacco
Di peccati
E quindi
Deve stare
Impurgatorio
E Caterina
Spiega a Dio
Che i patti
Non erano
Quelli
E che se manca
Qualcosa
Lei è disposta
A farsene carico
Si sveglia
E ha un dolore
Nel fianco
Che prima
Non aveva
Se lo porterà
Dietro
Per tutta la vita
Ma la notte
Dopo
Sogna
Che suo padre
È in paradiso
E la ringrazia
Si è presa
Lei
Nel suo
Corpo
La pena
Che aspettava
Suo padre
Ora
A questo punto
O sono andato un po' avanti
Con questa cosa
Siamo ancora fermi
A Caterina
Con i genitori
Che vogliono farla sposare
Ma le muore
La sorella
Eh pazienza
I genitori
Sono sempre lì
Che le cercano
Un marito
A un certo punto
Caterina dice
Chiaramente
No
Io non ne voglio
Sapere
Qui dovrei aprire
Una piccola parentesi
Forse
Sul fatto che la storiografia
Si è molto interrogata
Su questo
E tanti altri casi
Di giovani
Che nel medioevo
Dicono
No
Io non voglio
Sposarmi
Come volete voi
Voglio restare vergine
L'uomo non lo voglio
E molta storiografia
Si dice
Per una donna
Di allora
Per una ragazzina
Non c'erano
Tanti altri modi
Di dire
Io voglio
Voglio fare
Quel che voglio io
E non quel che volete voi
Lo paghi carissimo
Però è un modo
Per dire
Voglio fare
Quel che voglio io
Non mi fermo su questo
Vi butto lì
Questa cosa
Che è una riflessione
Su cui la storiografia
Si sta interrogando
Certamente
Caterina dice
Io non voglio
I genitori
Cercano di convincerla
Passa di casa
Un frate domenicano
Gli dicono
Senti
Parlale tu
Il frate le va a parlare
E sente
Che qui c'è qualcosa
Che questa ragazzina
Non è soltanto
Un'infatuata
C'è qualcosa
Dal suo punto di vista
Lei è sincera
Ci crede
Le dice
Ma vediamo
Sei davvero sincera
Sei disposta
A tagliarti i capelli
I capelli
I capelli sono la cosa
Più importante
Per una ragazzina
Da marito
Naturalmente
Caterina è bruttina
Lo dicono tutti
L'unica cosa bella
Sono i capelli lunghi
Caterina prende le forbici
E si taglia i capelli
Poi perché la mamma
Non se ne accorga
Si mette un velo
Sulla testa
Cosa che le ragazzine
All'epoca non portavano
Le donne sposate
Sì
Della cristianità
Mai sarebbero uscite
In strada
Senza un velo
Sui capelli
Perché sarebbe sembrata
Una cosa da svergognate
Ma le ragazzine
Invece sì
La mamma la vede
Che è sta roba
Toglitelo
No no no
La mamma si accorge
Che si è tagliata i capelli
Qui c'è la grande
Scenata
In famiglia
Con tutta la famiglia
Ecco
Questo è interessante
Forse dovevo fermarmi
Anche di più
Su questo
Già prima
Siamo
Nel medioevo
Fra virgolette
Noi potremmo pensare
Che loro fossero
Tutti pronti
Ad accettare
Che Dio parla
Alle ragazzine
Che le ragazzine
Hanno le visioni
Nemmeno per idea
La famiglia reagisce
Esattamente
Come reagirebbe
Una famiglia di oggi
Cioè
La ragazzina
Si è messa delle cose
Per la testa
Bisogna guarirla
Da queste stupidaggini
Non la riempiono di botte
Perché sono
Gran brava gente
Devo dire
Con una pazienza
Incredibile
Visto il tipo
Che era Caterina
Però le dicono
Guarda che non la spunti
Raimondo nella vita
Lo racconta testualmente
Le dicono
Virgolettato
Con noi non la spunti
Anche se ti sei tagliata
I capelli
I capelli ricresceranno
E ti faremo sposare
Anche se dovesse
Scoppiarti il cuore
Anzi no
Creparti il cuore
Dicono
Intanto
Già che ci siamo
Ti facciamo
Via i grilli per la testa
Comincia a lavorare
Che è sta storia
Che stai sempre in camera tua
A pregare
Ecco
Lavora
E la mettono a lavorare
In cucina
A lavare i piatti
22 fratelli
Voi capite
Vanno avanti
Per un po' così
E Caterina
Dura
Poi a un bel momento
Il padre
E sempre il padre
Anche per Giovanna d'Arco
Anche per Christine de Pisane
Vedrete se ci sarete domani
Dopodomani
E sempre il papà
La mamma è imbevuta
Dei valori convenzionali
Del tempo
La ragazzina
La faremo sposare
Il padre
Di fronte
Alla figlia femmina
Gli cede qualcosa
Comunque lei è più forte di lui
Non c'è niente da fare
Lei è più forte di lui
E a un certo punto
Il padre che la vede pregare
Si dice
No qui c'è qualcosa di strano
C'è qualcosa che non va
C'è davvero qualcosa di speciale
E dunque
Lasciamole fare come vuole lei
Ed è in questo preciso momento
Che sostanzialmente
Il padre decide
Che Caterina
Bisogna lasciarla fare
Come vuole lei
Cosa vuol dire
Lei vuol stare in casa
Per il momento
È ancora piccola
Vuol stare in casa
Libera di vivere la sua vita
Lei si è consacrata
Alla penitenza
Lei considera il suo corpo
Come un nemico
Ne riparleremo
Se avremo tempo
Forse no
Ma insomma ci proveremo
Vuole punire questo corpo
Quindi la vita di Caterina
Significa
Basta mangiare carne
Basta bere vino
Basta cibi cotti
A un certo punto
Comincia a nutrirsi
Di pane
Acqua
E verdure crude
Un cilicio
Di ferro
Alla vita
Raimondo Dacapo
E il suo confessore
Quando lei sarà più grande
Glielo fa togliere
Perché non ne può più
Di questa cosa del cilicio
Che lei ci muore
Glielo fa togliere
Lei per obbedienza lo toglie
Ma per anni l'ha portato
Frustarsi con catene di ferro
Diverse
Tre volte al giorno
Non dormire
E quindi dormire
Su un asse di legno
Apposta
Non sul materasso
Per cercare di dormire
Nemmeno possibile
In famiglia
Il padre
Il padre ha detto
La lasciamo fare
Come vuole come vuole
Come vuole lei
Perché è vero
C'è Dio che parla
Dentro questa ragazzina
Non possiamo farci niente
La madre è molto meno convinta
La madre è sconvolta
La vede morire sotto i suoi occhi
La vede dimagrire
De perire
Piena di lividi
Cerca di impedirglielo
Caterina
Tiene duro
La mamma
La porta alle terme
Oltre si pensa
Che nel medioevo
Fossero gente poco pulita
Al contrario
La tecnologia degli acquedotti
Non ce l'avevano
Ma i luoghi termali
Gli piacevano e come
La mamma
Le porta alle terme
Bagni di lucca
Immagino
Caterina dice
Sì però vorrei fare il bagno da sola
Poi va dove l'acqua è bollente
In modo
Caterina
Diventa
Una persona conosciuta
Si comincia a sapere
A Siena
E poi a Firenze
E poi in Italia
E poi fuori d'Italia
Che c'è questa ragazza straordinaria
Straordinaria non solo
Perché sta chiusa in casa
Murata in una camera
Da sola
Ma perché?
Perché fa una penitenza continua
E soprattutto perché Dio le parla
Perché Dio le parla
Le appare continuamente
E lei sa cosa dice Dio
E cosa vuole Dio
Quindi è anche una profetessa
E una che è in grado di dire
Ai potenti di questo mondo
Cosa devono fare
Come devono comportarsi
Ecco che dimenticavo una cosa
Che mi sembra importante
Quando la famiglia
Bene o male
Accetta di venire incontro
Alle richieste di Caterina
E lasciarla vivere come vuole lei
La prima cosa che lei dice è
In questa casa voi immaginate
Sovraffollata
Tutti i fratelli
Le sorelle
I nipotini
I bambini piccoli
I lavoranti
I garzoni
I domestici
In questo caso sovraffollata
Caterina dice
Voglio una stanza tutta per me
E' difficile che non ci venga in mente
Virginia Woolf
Una stanza tutta per sé
Cos'è che vuole una donna
Per rivendicare
Ecco una stanza tutta per sé
Caterina non è una femminista
Sia ben chiaro
Neanche lontanamente
Ma vuole una stanza tutta per sé
Chiaro che letture femministe
Della sua esperienza
Sono esistite nel novecento
E come
Noi possiamo considerarle magari
Con qualche dubbio
Ma ci sono state
Certamente Caterina
La stanza per sé la vuole
Poi in quella stanza per sé
La usa
Per vomitare quel che ha mangiato
E per massacrarsi il corpo
Con le catene di ferro
Dunque Caterina diventa famosa
E qui sono
Io sono un bivio
Al di là del fatto che mi sono già giocato
Tre quarti del mio tempo
E ho ancora un'infinità di cose da raccontarvi
Ma adesso vedremo come fare
Caterina qui è un bivio
Perché
O meglio no
Scusate
Io sono un bivio
Perché Caterina è innanzitutto una mistica
Caterina è una donna
Che ha dedicato il grosso della sua vita
A soffrire per amore di Cristo
E a vivere questa esperienza folle
Della comunicazione continua
Con Dio
Con Gesù
E con i Santi
Questa esperienza veramente folle
Che per lei è travolgente
Che le dà una forza
E che lei esprime
Nelle sue lettere
Nei suoi scritti
Con una forza
Ci sono lettere in cui lei racconta
Cosa sono per lei queste visioni
Queste visioni sono cose vere
Dio è lì fisicamente davanti a lei
Che la brucia
Lei brucia di questo calore
Lei sente l'amore di Dio
In una lettera lo dice
Ma non lo sentite voi
L'amore di Dio
È un caldo
Tale
Che se fossimo di pietra
Doveremmo già essere scoppiati
Talmente forte
E lei lo sente questo caldo
E quando Dio le appare
Le appare per
Tirarla fuori dal suo corpo
E farle fare cose pazzesche
C'è una lettera in cui lei descrive questa cosa
Dio l'ha tirata fuori dal suo corpo
Le ha strappato il cuore da dentro il corpo
E intorno lei sentiva i diavoli
Che urlavano per la rabbia
Di vedere lei che stava salendo a Dio
E non potevano impedirlo
Dov'è?
Allora le dimonia
Con esterminio gridavano sopra di me
Volendo impedire e allentare
Col terrore loro
Il libero e affocato desiderio
E i demoni la colpiscono
La picchiano
La massacrano
Ma lei sale
Il suo cuore l'ha strappato dal corpo
E sale in cielo
E Dio prende il suo cuore
E lo stampa sulla chiesa
Perché tutta la chiesa
Senta la sua voce
Attraverso il cuore di Caterina
Io mi rendo conto di essere del tutto inadeguato
A rendervi
Ciò che lei sentiva
E che lei sentiva davvero
Quando vi dicevo che sono un bivio
E perché io
Se volessi rendo giustizia a Caterina
Dovrei parlarvi per ore
Di queste sue esperienze mistiche
E per pochissimo di tutto il resto
Invece le esperienze mistiche
Le diamo per scontate
Diciamo così
L'affogare nel sangue di Cristo
Tutte queste lettere
In cui lei scrive alla gente
Dicendo
Voglio che tu affoghi con me
Nel sangue di Cristo
Io lascerei stare questo
E verrei invece
A un'altra dimensione di Caterina
Che secondo me
Vista da noi
È più
No stupefacente
No perché stupefacente
Anche quella
Ma possiamo forse capirla meglio
Almeno io
Con i miei limiti
Posso capirla meglio
Caterina
Caterina come vi dicevo
Diventa famosa
E questo è lo scarto interessante
Su cui volevo fermarmi con voi
Questo è un mondo
Va da sé
Patriarcale
Che alle donne
Riserva spazi molto limitati
Nel privato
Ma quando una donna
Ha fatto questo salto
Quando una donna
Si è imposta
Ed è chiaro a tutti
Che lei è un portavoce di Dio
Non importa più niente
Che sia una donna
Caterina è una delle persone
Più importanti del mondo
E Caterina è una delle persone
Più importanti della sua epoca
Tanto per cominciare
Intorno a lei
Si raccolgono i discepoli
Arriva gente
Che vuole vivere con lei
Farsi insegnare da lei
Si crea una comunità
Perché Caterina scrive tante lettere
E non sa leggere né scrivere
Ha imparato a un certo punto
Lei dice che ha imparato a leggere
Per miracolo
Poi deve aver anche imparato
Scrivere perché in qualche lettera
C'è scritto
Questa l'ho scritta io di mia mano
Verso la fine della vita
Ma il grosso delle lettere
L'è detta
Intorno a lei ci sono
Fedeli
Segretari
Discepoli
Preti
Chierici
Pronti ai suoi ordini
Caterina diventa celebre
Il Papa
Da Avignone
Viene a sapere
Che c'è questa donna straordinaria
E com'è il suo mestiere
Dice
Vediamo
A Caterina
Arriva la richiesta
L'ordine
Di presentarsi a una commissione
Dell'ordine domenicano
A cui lei si è affiliata
Nel frattempo
Da terziaria laica
A una commissione
Che deve un po' giudicare
Capirci chiaro
In questa storia
La commissione
La giudica
E decide
Che non c'è niente da fare
È proprio vero
Le visioni
Vengono da Dio
Allora il Papa
Le mette al fianco
Un uomo
Per sorvegliarle
L'ho detto all'inizio
Raimondo da Capua
Una donna
Ha bisogno di un confessore
Tutte le donne
Non soltanto le mistiche
Tanto più Caterina
Ha bisogno di un confessore
Solo un uomo
Può essere un confessore
È un sacramento
La confessione
Ci vuole un prete
Raimondo da Capua
È un frate domenicano
Un uomo scafato
Un uomo di mondo
Un uomo che conosce
La politica
Un uomo che non si fa
Fregare facilmente
Il Papa
Ordina a Caterina
Di prendere
Raimondo da Capua
Come suo discepolo
Caterina
Vi sono già ingannato
Vedete
Come suo confessore
Ma sta di fatto
Che nel giro
Di pochissimo tempo
Raimondo da Capua
Ha messo accanto
A Caterina
Per sorvegliarla
Perché dopo tutto
È una donna
E non si sa
Se non può fare
Delle sciocchezze
Raimondo da Capua
Diventa rapidamente
Il più fanatico
Dei suoi fedeli
E Caterina lo sa
C'è una lettera
In cui lei
Che lei manda
A qualcuno
Per tramite
Di Raimondo
E allora scrive
Non so se
Il re di Francia
Dice
Mando questa lettera
Per tramite
Di questo
Mio padre
E figliuolo
Raimondo da Capua
Formalmente padre
Il suo confessore
Di fatto
È diventato
Uno dei discepoli
Della sua comunità
Figliuolo
Ora
In questo contesto
Caterina
Comincia a fare
Politica
Della chiesa
Innanzitutto
Certo
Ma politica
E il contesto
È quello
Che io vi ho accennato
All'inizio
Ricordate il papa
Che non vuole venire in Italia
Perché hanno detto
Che lo ammazzano
Appena arriva
Ecco
Ampliamo un po'
Questo contesto
Io spero di non star
Correndo troppo
Bevo un sorso d'acqua
Così mi fermo un secondo
E raccogliamo le idee
Allora voi pensate
Cosa sta succedendo
Il papa
Il papato
La chiesa
La chiesa di Roma
Si è trasferita
Ad Avignone
Che è un po'
Come se oggi
Si trasferisse
In Pensilvania
Sostanzialmente
Perché quelli
Sono i rapporti
Di forza politici
Dell'epoca
Il regno di Francia
E la grande
Potenza
Del mondo cristiano
Il papato
È stato ad Avignone
Per 70 anni
Suscitando
Grandissime polemiche
Finalmente
È stato eletto
Un papa
Gregorio XI
Che ha promesso
Di tornare a Roma
Suscitando
Grandissime polemiche
E grandissime speranze
Caterina
È schieratissima
Questa cosa
Che al tempo suo
Finalmente
Finisca
Questo scandalo
Che il papa
Non sta a Roma
Finalmente
Il papa
Torna a Roma
Caterina
Si sente coinvolta
In prima persona
Dio le dice
Datti da fare
Tu
Devi intervenire
Per far sì
Che questa cosa
Succeda davvero
Perché papa Gregorio
Da solo
Non è detto
Che mantenga
La promessa
E Caterina
Comincia a scrivere
Al papa
Delle lettere
Tremende
In cui
Gli dice
Fate il vostro
Dovere
E gli dice
Gregorio
Un bel nome
C'è stato
Gregorio Magno
Santo
Quello era
Un santo
Perché non ci sono
Più santi
Adesso
Fate di essere
Santo come era
Santo lui
Cito
Perché erano
Perché erano di carne
Anche loro
E quello
Stesso
Dio
E ora
Che era
Allora
Non ci manca
Se non virtù
E poi
Scrive al papa
Si
Non ci manca
Se non virtù
E poi
Eccola qui
Venite dunque
In Italia
Eccetera eccetera
E ora che
Torniate a Roma
E questo
E' quello
Che io
Voglio
Vedere
In voi
Voglio
Dice Caterina
Al papa
E il papa
Beninteso
Riceve queste lettere
Che sono pubbliche
E tutti lo sanno
Che Caterina
Scrive queste cose
Al papa
E tutti sanno
Che Caterina
Parla con Dio
E a questo punto
Non importa più
Tanto
Se è una ragazza
Di 28
29 anni
Una donna
E una che parla
Con Dio
E il papa
Non è che può
Non rispondere
Il papa risponde
E
E umilmente
E Caterina
Continua a scrivergli
E ogni cosa
Che fa il papa
Caterina la controlla
Il papa nomina
Dei nuovi cardinali
Li avrà nominati bene
Li avrà scelti bene
Qui ho inteso
Che avete fatto
I cardinali
Credo che sarebbe
Onore di Dio
E meglio per noi
Che attendeste sempre
Di fare uomini
Virtuosi
Se si farà
Il contrario
Sarà grande
Vituperio
Di Dio
E guastamento
Della Santa Chiesa
Non ci maravigliamo
Poi
Se Dio
Ci manda
I suoi flagelli
Il papa
Fa i cardinali
E va dalla politica
Nomina i vescovi
I vescovi fanno schifo
Termine nostro
Caterina dice
Sono puzzolenti
Non sono ciò
Che noi vorremmo
Nel giardino
Della Santa Chiesa
Voi
Il papa
Occorre che ne
Traggiate i fiori
Puzzolenti
Pieni di immondizia
E di cupidità
Gonfi di superbia
Cioè i mali pastori
Che attossicano
Avvelenano
E imputridiscono
Questo giardino
E poi appunto
Il papa
Dice sempre
Che viene
E non viene
Io vi dico
Venite
E non aspettate
Il tempo
Che il tempo
Non aspetta
Voi
Io
Se fossi in voi
Temerei
Che il divino
Giudizio
Non venisse
Sopra di me
E poi
Finalmente
Siccome il papa
Non si smuove
Guardate
Che mi arrabbio
E mi lamento
In alto
Fate sì
Dove
Che io
Non mi richiami
A Cristo
Crocifisso
Di voi
Che ad altro
Non mi posso
Richiamare
Che non ci è
Maggiore
In terra
Quindi
L'autorità massima
E quelle
Sono io
In comunicazione
Con lui
Papa
Ora
Il punto cruciale
È che queste lettere
Non è che i potenti
Della terra
Quando le ricevono
Le cestinano
Noi non sappiamo
E non sapremo mai
Se Gregorio undicesimo
Quando gli arriva
Un'altra lettera
Di Caterina
Però
Fatto sta
Che il papa
Risponde
E risponde
Umilmente
Perché dentro
Questa ragazza
Che sta crepando
Di fame
Nel frattempo
A forza di digiunare
Parla Dio
E quindi il papa
Risponde
E i re
Rispondono
E tutti sanno
Che Caterina
È una donna
Importante
Una donna potente
A un certo punto
Succede una cosa
Che vi racconto
Molto rapidamente
Perché non c'è tempo
Ma
Fantasmagorica
Per l'epoca
Questo ritorno
Preventivato
Del papa
In Italia
Ha suscitato
Grandi commozioni
E scontri
A un certo punto
Scoppia una guerra
Tra Firenze
E il papa
Per ragioni politiche
Di controllo
Del territorio
Firenze è in guerra
Col papa
Non è per niente contenta
Firenze
Di avere la guerra
Col papa
Dopo un po'
Vorrebbero far la pace
Ma le cose
Si sono molto guastate
Come fare
Caterina
In quel momento
Vive a Firenze
Con la sua comunità
Il comune di Firenze
Che è una delle
Grandi potenze
Del mondo di allora
Per l'enorme ricchezza
Finanziaria
Di cui dispone
Chiama Caterina
E le dice
Non è che tu ci metteresti
Una buona parola
Col papa
E Caterina
Dice potrei anche
Se ti va
Ti mandiamo ad Avignone
Perché il papa
È ancora sempre là
La mandano ad Avignone
A incontrare il papa
Il comune di Firenze
Per chiedere al papa
Se per piacere
È disposto
Ad accettare
Un'ambasciata fiorentina
E intavolare
Negoziati di pace
E Caterina
Una donna
Arriva ad Avignone
E il papa
La riceve
E stanno da soli
A parlare
A lungo
E Caterina
Lo convince
A ricevere
Poi
L'ambasciata
Fiorentina
E finalmente
Il papa viene in Italia
E più o meno
Sono tutti d'accordo
Che se Caterina
Non avesse martellato
Così tanto
Non è detto
Che venisse
Invece viene
Gregorio XI
Viene in Italia
È finito
Il periodo
Avignonese
Purtroppo
Le cose
Vanno di male
In peggio
Gregorio XI
È arrivato in Italia
È venuto a Roma
Caterina
Si trasferisce
A Roma
Perché quello
È il centro
Degli avvenimenti
E lei si sente
Al centro
Degli avvenimenti
Si trasferisce
A Roma
Con
Una trentina
Di discepoli
E di amici
Che formano
La sua comunità
Più la mamma
Che è ancora viva
Ed è sempre con lei
Si trasferisce
A Roma
Per essere nel centro
Degli avvenimenti
Dopo un annetto
Che è arrivato
A Roma
Gregorio XI
Muore
Viene eletto
Un altro Papa
Che nel suo programma
Ha molto chiaramente
Il fatto
Di rimanere
A Roma
Nell'urbe
Lo esplicita
Chiaramente
Fin nel nome
Che sceglie
Si chiamerà
Urbano
Che vuol dire
Resterò a Roma
Urbano VI
Resto resta a Roma
Ma purtroppo
Molto presto
Si scopre
Che è un pessimo politico
Si rende impopolare
Commette un sacco di errori
Dopo qualche mese
Gli stessi cardinali
Che l'hanno eletto
E questa è una delle vicende
Più pazzesche
Della storia della Chiesa
Pubblicano un manifesto
Per dire che si sono sbagliati
A leggere lui
Si riuniscono di nuovo
E ne eleggono un altro
Il quale torna ad Avignone
A questo punto ci sono due papi
E lo scisma
Che durerà molti decenni
E che spaccherà
La cristianità euro-occidentale
In un modo drammatico
Oggi per noi
Inimmaginabile
Immaginate
Se ci fosse un papa a Roma
E uno a Pittsburgh
Ciascuno dei quali
Sostiene di essere il vero papa
Con i vari paesi
Che si schierano
Con l'uno
Con l'altro
Caterina è costernata
Da questa cosa
E comincia
Una campagna
Violentissima
Di lettere
Ai potenti
Di questo mondo
Per convincerli
Che il papa vero
È quello di Roma
E bisogna sostenere lui
Alcuni cardinali italiani
Peggio ancora
Perché i francesi
Si capisce
Preferiscono il papa ad Avignone
Ma alcuni cardinali italiani
Hanno partecipato
Alla nuova elezione
Caterina scrive
Una lettera tremenda
A questi cardinali italiani
Con desiderio
Di vedervi uscire
Da tante tenebre
E cecità
Nella quale siete caduti
Allora sarete padri
A me
In altro modo
No
E continua
Ripetendo appunto
A questi
A questi cardinali
Come siete
Matti
Che a noi
Deste la verità
Hanno eletto
Il papa giusto
E poi
Hanno cambiato idea
E per voi
Volete gustare
La bugia
Di qualunque lato
Io non ci trovo
Altro che bugie
Siete degni
Di supplizio
Ai cardinali
E poi
Comincia a scrivere
Ai vari re
E regine
E principi
Perché ogni stato
Deve decidere
Con che papa stare
E quindi lei fa
Lobbing
Per convincere
Il re di Francia
Il re di Napoli
Il duca d'Angio
E così via
A schierarsi
Col papa giusto
E scrive queste lettere
Anche a loro
Terribili
Al duca d'Angio
Lunga lettera
Per spiegargli
Che il papa vero
È quello di Roma
E poi chiude
Non dico di più
Ricordatevi
Monsignore
Che dovete morire
E non sapete
Quando
Scrive alla regina
Di Napoli
Fra donne
Scrive alla regina
Di Napoli
Con un tono
Di intimità
Particolare
Carissima
E reverenda
Madre
Parentesi
Cara
Mi sarete
Quando
Vi vedrò
Figliuola
Assidua
E obbediente
Alla santa chiesa
Reverenda
In quanto
Vi renderò
La debita reverenza
Quando
Ne sarete degna
Abbandonando
La tenebra
Dell'eresia
E seguendo
La luce
Altrimenti
No
Ecco
Quello che va detto
Di Caterina
Mi avvio a concludere
Il tempo
Passa
Chiudiamo
Ma c'è ancora
Qualcosina da dire
In questa sua
Abitudine ormai
Negli ultimi anni di vita
È l'abitudine
A parlare
Con i potenti
Di questo mondo
Parlare
È Dio
È Dio che parla
In lei
Naturalmente
Ma di fatto
È Caterina
Che fa scrivere
Che detta
Che parla
Con questo tono
C'è alla fine
Anche un egocentrismo
Formidabile
Lo stesso
Che la spinta
In famiglia
A fare
Quel che voleva
E ottenere
Quando
La regina di Napoli
Nonostante tutto
Prima si era schierata
Col papa giusto
La regina di Napoli
Poi
Poi cambia idea
Si schiera
Dall'altra parte
Caterina le scrive
Una cosa
Che oggi
Ci può suonare
Un po' sgradevole
E cioè le dice
Avete dimostrato
Di essere una femmina
Vana e debole
Come foglia al vento
E non virile
Come dovrebbe essere
Una regina
Che dovrebbe essere
Come un vero uomo
E oltre a questo
Questo è per la serie
Non era una femminista
Dopotutto
Ma oltre a questo
Caterina
La regina di Napoli
Scrive questo
Dice ma come è possibile
Che non accettiate
La verità
Come è possibile
Che
Che non abbiate capito
Quale che non vogliate
Fare la cosa giusta
E dice
Caterina
Ma forse
Forse Dio
Ha voluto
Che io faccia ancora
Penitenza
Dei miei peccati
E quindi
Per farmi fare
Ancora più penitenza
Dei miei peccati
Non ha voluto
Darmi questa soddisfazione
Di vedere
Che la regina di Napoli
Si è schierata
Dalla parte giusta
Cioè qui vedete
Io lo chiamo
Egocentrismo
Forse non va bene
Come parola
Perché lei
È folle in Dio
Naturalmente
No
Però lei vede
Chiaramente se stessa
Come l'intermediaria
Fra Dio e il mondo
Quindi tutto passa
Attraverso di lei
E se la regina di Napoli
Sbaglia
È perché Dio
Ha voluto punire Caterina
Per non dare a lei
Questa soddisfazione
Con quelli
Appena al di sotto
Della regina di Napoli
Caterina non si fa scrupoli
Non si fa scrupoli
E difende anche
Interessi concreti
Non dimentichiamolo
Perché Caterina
Terziaria
Domenicana
Con una sua comunità
Legatissima
Ad altre comunità
Di suore
Di terziari
Con cui ha
Amicizie
E così via
E ha stretti rapporti
E difende
Queste comunità
Quando ce n'è bisogno
Le sue lettere
Ai potenti
Non sono solo
Indicazioni complessive
Su cosa andevano fare
Nella grande politica
Ma sono anche
Interventi molto concreti
L'arcivescovo di Pisa
E in lite
Con le monache
Di Santa Caterina
Di Pisa
E un'altra Santa Caterina
Ma sono amiche sue
Comunque
Loro hanno
Un certo privilegio
Su Pisa
E' stato buttato
L'interdetto
Pisa è in rotta
Con la chiesa
Col Papa
Il Papa fa una cosa
Che all'epoca
Si faceva spesso
Per punizione
Di questa città
Getta l'interdetto
Il che vuol dire
Non si può celebrare
La messa
Nella città di Pisa
Finché i pisani
Non vengono
A più miti consigli
E' una cosa pesante
Le monache
Di Santa Caterina
Hanno un privilegio
Papale
Che dice che loro
Possono dire messa
Nel loro convento
Anche se c'è
L'interdetto
L'arcivescovo di Pisa
Non è d'accordo
Contesta questa cosa
Dice anche voi
Dovete rispettare
L'interdetto
Scusate se è una cosa
Complicata
Ma è per dare sugo
A quello che scrive
Poi Caterina
All'arcivescovo
Voi volete
Che tengano
L'interdetto
Dicendo
Che il privilegio
Che hanno
Non vale
E io vi dico
Che vale
Perché io
Mostrai la copia
Quando io fui
A Avignone
Al Santo Padre
E lo accettò
Lei parla
Personalmente
Col Papa
Capito
Lo va a trovare
Altro che
Arcivescovo di Pisa
Stia al suo posto
E così
Quando certe monache
Di Siena
Le scrivono
Che hanno dei problemi
Perché c'è un giovanotto
Malvissuto
Della zona
Che molesta
Le giovani monache
Avete presente
La monaca di Monza
Egidio
Ecco
Anche lì
Il giovanotto
Molesta le giovani monache
Ha fatto addirittura
Un buco nel muro
Entra nel monastero
Lei scrive
Al podestà di Pisa
Bisogna punirlo
Questo giovane
Non vorrei però
Che egli perdesse
La vita
Ma ad ogni altra pena
Io sarei molto
Consolata
In altre lettere
Già che c'è
Dopo lunghe dissertazioni
Sul sangue di Cristo
Scrive
Ricordatevi
Dico i due processi
Che vi ho detto
Perché
Quelle brave monache
Hanno quella causa
In corso
E hanno ragione loro
E quindi
Mi raccomando
Tenete presente
Quindi insomma
Caterina è una donna
Che si muove
A 360 gradi
Nel mondo
Del potere
Invasata
Dell'amore di Dio
E che sa
Quando è il caso
Intervenire anche
In cose molto concrete
Nel frattempo
Si ammazza
Di digiuni
Tutti i suoi confessori
L'hanno sgridata
Per questo
Tutti i suoi confessori
Gli hanno detto
Non è possibile
Devi mangiare
Anche Raimondo
Da Capo
Gli l'ha detto
C'è una lettera
Fantastica di Caterina
Che scrive
In risposta a Raimondo
Raimondo le ha detto
Devi mangiare
E Caterina gli scrive
E gli dice
Ma io
Io ho pregato Dio
Che mi aiutasse
Che mi facesse mangiare
Non ci riesco
Non vuole Dio
Che io mangi
Non lo so
Forse le mie preghiere
Non sono abbastanza forti
Pregate voi
Se possibile
Che Dio mi faccia mangiare
Perché io sono disposta
Ma non ci riesco
E Raimondo scrive
Che Caterina
È arrivata a un punto tale
Che anche solo
L'odore della carne
La fa star male
Lui è talmente spaventato
Vedendola morire
Che a un certo punto
Le fa mettere di nascosto
Dello zucchero nell'acqua
Lei beve solo acqua
Naturalmente
Mangia pane
E verdure crude
Le fa mettere un po'
Di zucchero nell'acqua
Lei si accorge
Che c'è lo zucchero
Sta male
E gli dice
Ma volete avvelenarmi
E Raimondo dice
Sì è raggiunta
A un punto tale
Che a un po' di dolce
Non lo reggeva più
E c'è anche chi
La critica per questo
E questo non l'ho detto
Milioni di cose
Non vi ho detto stasera
Ma pazienza
Ormai è finita
Caterina
Ha i suoi detrattori
Ha quelli che dicono
Figuriamoci se non mangia
Di nascosto mangia come
Altrimenti come farebbe
Essere ancora viva
Ha i suoi detrattori
Che dicono
Sì certo
Parla con Dio
È molto contenta
Di parlare con Dio
E il peccato di presunzione
Di vanagloria
Dove è finito
Circolano poesie
Su di lei
Canzoni
Poemi
Che ne parlano anche male
Or ti guarda
Suora mia
Che non cada
In gran rovina
Se tu hai
Grazia divina
Fa che l'abbi
Conservata
Se lo spirito
Ti mena
Che non vuol dire
Ti picchia
Ma ti conduce
Se lo spirito
Ti mena
Non cercarlo
Da terrena
I detrattori
Sostanzialmente
Sostengono
Che a Caterina
Tutto sommato
L'applauso
L'acclamazione
Del mondo
Non dispiacesse tanto
Chi lo sa
Fatto sta
Che nel frattempo
Lei si ammazza
All'inizio
Del 1380
Le cose vanno
Di male
In peggio
Urbano VI
È impopolare
Il Papa di Avignone
Sta vincendo
Tutto quello
Per cui
Lui si è data
Da fare
Negli ultimi anni
Sta crollando
Caterina decide
Che d'ora in poi
Non solo non mangerà
Ma non berrà
Neanche più
Va avanti
Qualche settimana
Senza bere
Poi sta morendo
La costringono
A bere
Si riprende
Un attimo
Va avanti
Ancora qualche mese
Muore lo stesso
Siamo nel 1380
In quello stesso momento
Molto lontano
Da lì
A Parigi
Una ragazzina
Di 15 anni
Che non conosce
Nessuno
Che si chiama
Christine de Pisan
Si sposa
Con l'uomo
Che la sua famiglia
Ha scelto per lei
Esattamente
La cosa
Che Caterina
Ha rifiutato
Ostinatamente
Di fare
A costo di ammazzarsi
Pur di non farla
Nel momento stesso
In cui Caterina muore
Christine
Ha 15 anni
Si sposa
E comincia
Una fase
Della sua vita
Ma questa
È una storia
Che racconteremo domani
Grazie
Grazie.